[Music]
how many of you guys have
stocks i do does the retirement
account yeah yes yes yeah we do too yes
we can raise our hands i raise
my hand for you thanks both of you guys
that's awesome yeah so have you guys uh
you know dealt it and bought you buy and
sell like daytrade do you guys know
jason chen
yes he's my he's my stocks expert so
really yeah hit him up for uh
all your coaching oh listen to his music
he's on you right now tell me to buy
bitcoin and that's as far as it goes
right now he's
trying to tell you to buy bitcoin okay
what i hear right now is the time to
sell
yes a lot of people are saying right now
is a very good time
to sell and depending on who wins the
election
it they could uh you should be selling
different things and
for jeff bezos he recently unloaded
three
billion dollars worth of amazon shares
god damn
this [ __ ] this guy knows how he's
moving the entire market
with that yeah and he's definitely he's
he's setting the trend for what's going
to happen right now i just bought some
amazon
oh you [ __ ] maybe you should sell
when did this news come out
this news came out november 4th on
wednesday today's friday so two days ago
okay he uh he sold more than three
billion dollars worth of
his shares and um and this
also just fun fact this brings his total
cash out in the year 2020
to 10 billion dollars what is that what
does that mean
what is that go for so as if he wasn't
the richest man already
why is he so greedy maybe he maybe he's
just smart he just sees the game
i don't know already sitting in number
one is it just more like i need to know
how far
far is like you know what i mean yeah
yeah i'm number one and i wanna i wanna
i wanna make number two look like he's
[ __ ] that's great
that's great that's great i'm just kind
of understanding
it didn't really affect the stock though
it's still the same price
oh yeah ish yeah well that's good i
thought yourself
[Laughter]
you're like teacher he's not on airplane
mode
he's using the wi-fi
yeah it dropped right before and it went
back up to normal so it was at 3 000
maybe that's when he
went to 2900 and it went to 3 000. it's
not that significant because earlier
this year
what's crazy is before the pandemic he
unloaded
and that's um that's an insider trading
[ __ ] yeah
amazon was like at sixteen hundred
dollars and i was like oh [ __ ] i better
get some right now
i got a [ __ ] and forgot about it was
it [ __ ] worth it
no it's not worth it oh it might be in
like you know a couple days you never
know
true yeah well i guess it's the volume
right because if you think about it
right now it's 3
000 so it doubled from 16 ish yeah but
you're nut halved
so you gotta cover your nut that's true
i just sorry i'm
i'm still on the airplane mode that he
didn't get back to me hey
we're trying to play on airplane mode
and turn on wi-fi
okay tiffa tell him we'll tell him the
truth joseph
you cannot because if you receive a text
message
it will [ __ ] up the audio for these
beautiful people watching well good
thing nobody texts me
okay good you got in trouble
i had to do it it was for research
purposes for sure yeah
it was for this reason and i had a
chance to check my dms real quick but
the real thing is speaking of the
[ __ ] yeah he's getting more
inquiries
i think uh it's crazy because the idea
behind
gains and stocks and all this stuff too
the more i talk to traders and whatever
um they don't see money the way that we
do well because they're not even trading
money dude
yeah technically they're just digits
yeah you know true
and they're just playing with these
numbers they're baseball cards yeah
literally like it's like trading pokemon
cards it's like that scene on wolf on
wall street when he's explaining
what stocks are and how like they make
money so they're like just keep them in
the [ __ ] game
just keep them in the wheel because it's
not even money i don't know i don't
understand it at all
yeah no i'm just referring to the whole
greek comment when i was
searching for the uh yeah he's greedy
he's greedy
you think so well they're saying these
transactions that he
so he's already pulled out 10 billion
this year right and um
they're saying that it's actually part
of a prearranged
correct me if you know this 10b 5-1
trading plan
yeah that sounds about right yep exactly
so what a 10b 5-1 thing i don't i don't
even know how to
say that but it's a it's it's one zero
just kidding
it's actually one zero b five one uh
uh it's a government uh program to help
i guess rich people
not uh do insider trading or like
prevent them from doing insider training
trading so then uh there's pre-arranged
uh ways for these billionaires to uh
unload their stocks and then once they
unload it there's a
predetermined uh funding that the money
goes to
so for bezos uh you know he wants to
put he can be putting this money into
his startup for blue
origin or he could be giving it to
uh earth fund which is to combat the
effects of climate change
uh and you know issues grants to
scientists activists and other
organizations
so there's a lot of uh i guess on the
back end of it
there's a lot of reasons why he's you
know given up this money
uh it's one to prevent the the insider
trading
two it goes to a noble cause like a
philanthropic kind of cause and so
that's what people are speculating as to
why he's pulling all this money out at
this
moment are people mad at him uh i don't
know i don't know that's just
speculation though
yes because it hasn't been announced who
the recipients of the funds are
so we don't know where the money's
actually going to yet um but they did
say they named the
nature conservancy or the environmental
defense fund
or the natural resource resources
defense council
and or the world wildlife fund wow
i don't know so i guess i bring this up
because you know he could be the evil
uh rich guy that's trying to be number
one in the world or he could also just
be trying to collect a lot of money to
help the world i don't know
he i think he is number one now i think
he surpassed bill gates he doesn't i
think he's and he's he's
creating a distance too now damn big ass
he's gonna be the first trillionaire
that's crazy you're saying he sold three
billion
stock or three billion dollars worth of
stock three billion dollars worth of
stock yeah where'd the tent come from i
heard
oh for the whole year so february yeah
so back in february he pulled out
a four point three point one billion
no no february 4.1 billion and then in
august he pulled out 3.1 billion
and then now another three billion and
people are speculating that
of that 10 billion he's gonna donate how
much either to these funds we don't know
we don't know how he's gonna divvy up
this money
what he's gonna use it for or it could
be bad uh he could just be buying his
stock back too later when it's lower
yeah and that would be the bad thing
right i mean that's what has happened in
the past
that bad or is that like i don't know
this [ __ ]
do you know if it's good or bad like
what is that i just know that um
oh my god a lot of these top like okay
if you look at the
isn't that how they make money making a
ton of money
like if you just see the gdp or whatever
right like if you're
if you're already in stocks people are
making a [ __ ] ton right now
so it makes no sense because how is the
economy doing
well if the economy isn't flowing
online movement no stimulus money yes
so all of this is just [ __ ] free
money being
injected and like whatever but also it's
like rich people already had money
so so there's two things going on right
a ton of free money
but people who saved up because of the
last recession
so last recession when the housing
crisis and all this [ __ ] went out
a lot of people weren't ready for that
so they're like oh [ __ ]
like i'm living paycheck to paycheck
right but then
after that happened so like let's say if
that was us
in our 20s or whatever right by the time
now we're in our 40s or
or or we have families we're smarter we
have jobs we have careers
we have better paid [ __ ] right like we
saved up we
we went through the recession so we're
like all right we don't we don't want
this [ __ ] to go down again
so we're saving up because we're hearing
about this crash that's happening
and it's not even here so then now all
these prices
stock prices are like dipping so they're
like oh [ __ ] well [ __ ] it i'm gonna buy
so there's like all these other things
that's happening and so
that is where like a lot of the money is
kind of being cycled but then this is
where
the point i'm trying to make here is the
rich is getting richer and then like the
poor's just kind of like
stuck because it's like if they don't
get the checks
they're [ __ ] because the economy is
not flowing like
the cities aren't opening it's like how
are these companies doing so well
aside from amazon if people aren't
purchasing
the way that they used to right right so
it doesn't make any sense yeah so what
you're saying is we should buy
stocks if you can afford it
i don't know i mean no financial advice
here you know i'm just kind of
playing but it seems like anything or a
lot of things are doing well right now
so if you just put into anything you'll
just do well
i see interesting answers do you think
then
uh depending on who wins presidency then
there's gonna be
different moves to be making then yeah
because there will be a change
either way uh the election goes uh yeah
i think
so for example right like airlines
they're probably going to struggle for a
while
i mean it's not if trump or biden wins
we don't know
if the world is going to open up so like
buying airline stocks right now is
probably not a good idea
but then let's say uh depending on
which president wins there's different
interest groups that will benefit so if
trump wins real estate's gonna
probably do well because all the laws
that are put into place he's not going
to let that fail because
he has so many things like personally
invested into real estate
it's kind of like when bush won you
could pretty much guarantee that oil is
going to do
well because his family is like killing
it on oil
like that's what they're invested into
right so it just depends on which
president it has a lot of friends in
what company and like
how they're gonna manipulate the laws
and everything to benefit
them and their their friends yeah it's
all a [ __ ] game
it's a big [ __ ] game man that's what
i've been saying it sounds weird when
you're like you know when the president
and like which friends he's got
you're like oh man i wish i was his
friend yeah we got some powerful friends
man
we're gonna start hanging with some like
politicians or something yeah but this
[ __ ] they do
i don't want to get killed i'm not down
i like i really like house of cards
though
can't you can you if you found out some
deep secret [ __ ] right
about politician [ __ ] yeah and then like
knowing like there's
your life is on the line i'd probably
get killed immediately
because you tell all the secrets that's
how big of a mouth you're at yeah i'd
just be like yo can you believe this
guy's doing this well maybe he's not a
big man maybe it's uh he
he just has the capacity to tell the
truth
you can ask me anything and i'll
probably pretty much i'll take a secret
to my grave
if it's about me if it's about me i'll
pretty much say it's about corruption
but yeah if i knew somebody was doing
some crazy [ __ ] like that
uh yeah i'd probably get murked right
away i'd probably they'd probably kill
me
off the jump okay let's keep you safe
like house of cards the other day don't
tell nick
i haven't seen him tell me oh [ __ ]
kevin's basically gonna push me in front
of a train
spoiler oh let's go there sorry it's
easy
okay i stopped watching after like this
yeah spoilers sorry
i think everyone stopped by don't you
this character's name everyone stopped
watching once that fool was all pervy
yeah that too that's who i stopped why
didn't it really stop when trump came
into office
because this real politics got more
entertaining yeah
that's true that's very true first
couple seasons in the house card was
dope it was good man very good first two
seasons
yeah and then he started kissing the
security guard or something like that
yeah his
secret spoiler alert yeah another
spoiler alert
very diverse show we have not seen the
show now you just spoiled it you guys
it's in case you chris this guy yeah it
does spoiler alerts is his life
[Laughter]
no definitely did you hear what happened
to david spoiler alert yeah
[Music]
you